some of you will be surprised to learn
that one of the hottest products out
there
is slime
yeah kids love to play with it and i am
telling you because
it's in every single one of the fibers
of my carpets
it's all over my house and the thing
that's really interesting though
about slime is it is an art and there's
a lot of social media on it a ton of
tutorials this is like
a real thing and a movement out there
and there's actually a really
interesting soothing aspect to it
and when my teachers were telling me
like please don't let your daughter
bring stuff in her backpack
with like squishies and slime they it's
very sensorial
and so it's very soothing to a lot of
people and today we have a slime
expert to tell us more she's actually an
amazing entrepreneur to her
uh too and i really really love her
story
so please welcome teen slime
entrepreneur jay kang hi
[Music]
[Applause]
you know we've actually been really
excited about the prospect of you coming
here because you launched
snoop slimes when you were just 13 years
old
how well ever since
i was six years old i wanted to become
an entrepreneur and i would always write
down
on my you know dream journal that i
always wanted to
you know own a business but i just never
knew when that time would come
but you know in the summer of 2016 i was
just scrolling through instagram
like a normal teenager and i found out
that
you know these people are playing with
this stuff called slime and at first i
didn't really know much about it so i
decided to do more digging and research
into it
and realize that people are actually
selling this product so i decided to ask
my mom if she could help me invest 200
into this business that i want to start
and you know
in the beginning my sister was like you
know we can just get a fancy dinner with
those 200
you know but um i decided to use those
money
and invested into the ingredients that i
needed to make my first slime
and after that i opened my first etsy
shop i started my slime account on
instagram
and after two weeks i started getting
some sales and just blew up from there
i mean you have a full-on
slime office with four employees
four how does it feel to be the ceo
of a company it feels amazing you know
being able to
have my own schedule every single day
being my own boss
it's you know so amazing and also being
able to be creative
you know waking up in the morning having
to
think of new slime ideas and just being
able to
look at so many different things and so
many different aspects of business like
it's amazing and it's really difficult
to sometimes balance school life
and business life and social life with
my friends but with my time management
skills i'm able to cope with all those
and work it all out
well will you teach me um how to do some
slime right now
i mean and by the way i hope my daughter
you know daughters are
you know so savvy like you i'm gonna
love them
obviously no matter what and i'm so
excited to see you know
like my daughters already think they
know what they want to do and maybe
those
dreams will stick but i love supporting
them
and it's funny because as an adult slime
is like it really
gets messy in your house when your kids
are working with it and i've always
supported them i'm like play with the
slime i'll figure it out i'll clean it
up okay so teach me
what do we do all right true so we'll be
making a candy corn inspired slime since
halloween is coming up soon
so we're first going to pour two cups of
glue
into the bowl by the way i wish is this
is what the slime
kit in my house looks like olive just
makes her own ratios
it's all over the place i mean she's
like a mad scientist
i call her the alchemist arsonist which
i know sounds like a really dark name
but she really is she loves to get into
everything
yeah it's all an experiment all right
now we're gonna add one teaspoon of
baking soda
into the same bowl uh-huh done and
we're gonna use a spatula and we're
gonna mix both of these ingredients
up together and just mix it through
you gotta make sure everything's just
all mixed
my god literally i am in olive's happy
place right now
if we were playing with like barbies and
princesses i'd be in frankie's happy
place
all right now we're to take some
contacts one solution
yep right here just a little bit at a
time
into the slime you don't want to make it
you know you don't want to pour too much
in because it will make the slime too
stiff so just keep pouring a little bit
don't pour too much
there you go yep and it just keeps
stirring
keep stirring drew um that's a contact
solution
yeah that makes sense i see all these
bottles of like empty optifresh all over
the floor
so yeah that makes sense okay i think we
might need to add a little bit more so
add a little bit more context on
solution okay
you want the slime to start getting off
the
start unsticky oh oh oh okay
keep mixing oh okay you know what by the
way
i think what we can do also is like
turn this into a workout i think maybe
if you open a gym membership
to a slime factory and then we can
like the moms can help their kids by
working out their mom arms
oh
can i please add these these are my
favorite these are my absolute favorite
can i i did i someone else made this
wonderful slime let's face it i did
not make this but i'm adding the colored
balls in
oh god now i'm going rogue i'm fired
keep adding it and and i've got googly
eyes
i'm just i'm going for it cause we're
going to commercial and i'm like you
know what
my slime's getting everything
how does this look that looks amazing
oh god by the way i'm not
kidding if anyone has any interest
please go on social media and get into
the slime world because it is
so relaxing it is so artistic it really
is a very
important movement for people and
like it's so nice to meet you and it is
so nice to see
a young woman such as yourself
doing so much with your life at such a
young age you are such an inspiration
and my daughter is going to be so
jealous of this segment when she sees it
i'm in deep trouble
so do you mind if i uh sidebar with you
jay
and um maybe see how if if i could ever
like facetime you with her
i would love to send her any signs that
she would like
oh my god she'll be your biggest fan jay
and we are too
thank you so much for coming
you